[Music]
there's cracks everywhere imagine
calling this place your home there's
mold there
then imagine you've been sent here after
years of physical and mental abuse from
your partner it's not even a window
i feel like i'm in prison
i don't even know when it's sunny or
raining outside this family lived their
lives in this windowless room
i never thought that life would be like
this that my children suffer like this
just four walls in a broken bathroom
this is the reality for some of
britain's most vulnerable
there's a crisis going on now that the
people in power don't like to talk about
[Music]
tens of thousands of domestic abuse
victims are being failed by the system
there's not nearly enough accommodation
to house them after they've left their
violent relationships
and the ones who managed to get shelter
are moved into places that are barely
livable prisoners in their own homes
i've had cases where women have just
given up and have gone back to their
perpetrator
our investigation reveals a broken
system that seems to punish victims
instead of helping them on the ground
what you have found is the reality for
the majority
i start my journey in the north of
england
i'm meeting a woman who has just escaped
after decades of abuse just obviously
just keep it down now
we're calling a susan not a real name to
protect her identity
she's in hiding now
this is a safe house hello i'm andy from
sky we're invited in
can you try and explain what it's like
being stuck in that
daily cycle of violence against you
when it got into like a regular thing
you knew what was coming
so i used to just
take it and brace yourself embrace
myself yeah i mean it could be anything
like if the tea were done properly or he
didn't get his teeth first
um
or if i didn't walk the streets at two
o'clock at morning just to go and get
him some alcohol
i'd get a beating
and how regular were they every day
and i stopped with that for 27 years
um
so i got away from that then i was put
in like all
he found me in
one of the hotels in town
so i've been moved around from pillar to
pulse since then
susan's story is a familiar one for
abuse victims only one in three are
accepted into refuges because most are
full or have closed due to government
cuts
if they can't get in the victims are
placed into so-called temporary
accommodation
it took susan several weeks before she
was moved into a small two-bedroom
property but it felt like anything but
home
the room that we're in now
was there any furniture at all there was
nothing in here at all there was no
curtains
nothing no carpets nothing at all it was
just completely blank walls so how where
did you sleep
i slept on the floor um
i did rip a bit of cardboard down to try
and put on the floor and
i used one of me dirty washing bin bags
for a pillow
to make it more comfy did you have a
quilt tool no i had no
no blankets not me freezing
i was um but i put layers of clothes on
what did you do and how did you relax
before this sofa was here
i sat on the floor
doing what
just sitting on the floor twiggling me
thumbs um
just waiting for things to get and put
in place and the gas the electric
the furniture
um i couldn't do nothing else really
it's been awful it was
that's so typical of
so many stories i mean we could be
listening to
that every day
when we speak to people really it's
that's not
as horrific as that is that's not
unusual domestic violence is a huge
problem but housing
is not given the priority that we need
to with regards to safeguarding if we
think about those statutory partners we
think we think education we think social
care we think health but why is housing
not included in that why is it not given
a priority because actually
safeguarding has to be understood at a
housing level as well
if anything is to change then it must
happen here
the government has pledged 125 million
pounds for emergency accommodation for
domestic abuse victims this year
but campaigners say that's not nearly
enough
and there are now more women needing
help than ever before according to the
uk's largest abuse charity refuge
it's very very serious all mainstream
political parties agree something needs
to be done the whole system is broken
and um
and the government have a good line to
say at the dispatch box and councils no
doubt think that they're doing as much
as they can but in in reality
this has to be a political priority and
if you do not stretch every muscle to
deal with the entire system at every
level
i'm afraid to say that you are
happy to sit back and let
vulnerable women and children live in
dangerous
and unsavory accommodation that is not
fit for human habitation women expect to
come forward
and
be provided with reasonable services and
it's a big huge thing to break free of
such exploitation
and what they find is exactly what their
perpetrator promised them they find a
system that doesn't believe them that
treats them like animals that places
them in dangerous situations
and a huge amount of them will describe
it as going from one hell to another
when it comes izzy mulholland is a
lawyer who specializes in helping
domestic abuse victims find suitable
accommodation do you think that the law
helps domestic abuse victims i'm
frustrated and angry
almost daily
because i'm having to
defend people who shouldn't need
defending
and
the most frustrating thing and it seems
ridiculous is that we win
and that means that a local authority
accepts that they're acting unlawfully
and we don't just win some of the times
we win almost all the time
and that is so frustrating because it
means that if a lawyer gets involved
they will deliver the service that they
always should deliver
but it just takes a lawyer to tell them
to do it
and that is so frustrating
because it just my job shouldn't be
necessary
there's more temporary accommodation
facilities in london than anywhere else
in the country that means many women and
their children are moved here from their
hometowns
i've come to meet one of these young
families in bnb accommodation in the
capital
the law says vulnerable people shouldn't
be at places like this one for more than
six weeks
[Music]
as it's harmful to their physical and
mental health
but aisha and her three children have
spent more than two years here and
there's no sign of that changing
you've got three beds here obviously
there's there's four of you
so you and the little one on here
there's mold there mold everywhere
this
this
drain doesn't even work
you can't even
wash yourself some days that's where the
ants come from
this is nowhere to live
can you describe your emotions when you
actually first saw this room
when i first arrived i thought i would
receive some support
i was told i would only be here for a
while before we got a new home but we're
still here they're not supporting me or
my children we can't do anything in here
it's hard to explain how bad it is
i'm always tense i haven't even got a
house
it's really hard living here
my children can't get a good life here
sometimes i feel like i'm living on the
streets because i don't have a house
it's like i'm homeless
i feel like i'm in prison
i don't even know when it's sunny or
raining outside
have you tried to move somewhere else
have you tried to tell people that
you're not happy here
yes i tell the council all the time but
they say i'm not high risk
do you feel that you are high risk
of course i am all the time my children
ask me any news from the council do you
ever regret leaving even though
that house was so violent
i never thought that life would be like
this
that my children suffer like this
i will bear all the sufferings in the
world but i can't bear to see my
children suffer
aisha's 13 year old son agreed to speak
to me
when you first walked through these
doors
what was your first reaction
am i going to be staying here is this
for real this is an abomination
basically when i'm here i just spend all
my time in bed i even eat in bed did you
think that it would be possible to to
live in a room like this for two years
no not at all i've got asthma and i have
to put up with cigarette smoke in the
corridors all the time
what impact do you think living in this
place has on your
on your mum
she must be walking around with a lot of
weight on her shoulders she must always
be thinking when are we going to move
out of this place what do you hope
that the future holds for you
i just want a good place to live in
a place which is good for our health
seeing my mother struggle was very very
painful
we asked the government for an interview
with the minister about the testimonies
we gathered they said no one was
available but gave this statement
it is absolutely vital that victims of
domestic abuse and their children across
the country can access practical and
emotional support to help them rebuild
their lives in a safe environment
people often say to me and i hear this
again and again i can get over the thing
that happened to me the trauma that
happened to me
what
i can't get over is how traumatizing the
process was for me and my family
you couldn't pinpoint this on one aspect
this is a systemic failing in
safeguarding
domestic abuse should be something that
everybody's behind i think we can all
agree on it
domestic abuse survivors
should be helped
when they need it
so why aren't they
[Music]
you